- I couldn't stand up in front of a crowd.
Everything was just intimidating to me.
- I was a fish out of water.
They're gonna think I'm a
crazy girl with a camera
asking them do a pose for me.
This is for the yearbook.
- Oh, you should join the band.
I'm, like, I don't know.
- I've always been short,
so I'm just thinking
about the others watching me.
- I can't even count how nervous I was.
- [Girl] Like the year before I was.
- [Girl] I feel free.
- [Boy] Then make it creative.
- [Girl] I didn't like anybody.
- [Girl] There is no reason to go
if you're not going to give it your all.
- It's really hard studying for the SAT
especially as a senior because you have
so many things to do.
- Whether you want to do it or
you don't, it all starts now.
- I will feel confident
if I practice more.
- Some people come in talented,
but that's not enough.
You have to set goals
that you have to hit.
- I will put a 110% 'cause
this is what I want to do.
This is my goal, and I
want to accomplish it.
- Look at me now.
I'm number one, I'm in charge.
To the rear heart.
- If it's state championship
or test like the SAT,
it all comes from practice
which you've been doing before.
- You shouldn't be as scared
to do it the second time
because you already know what to expect.
- The point of doing it is so your brain
has that muscle memory like a
second nature kind of thing.
- You've got it.
You remember this.
- [Boy] The game goes silent.
(upbeat music)
- In the moment, you don't really realize
that shift of confidence.
- You've trained so hard
to know what to expect,
and then once you see it, it's like, wow!